hey youtubers it's Charlie and the first
trailer for guardians of the galaxy is
finally here and it looks amazing
so I wanted to do a larger preview for
the movie that included some of the
background on the characters as well as
some of the things that were different
about the comic book because they really
just rebooted it last year and it has
been awesome since there's so much stuff
going on in the Marvel Universe right
now the movie universe I'm probably
gonna start doing movie videos every
Tuesday since that's normally my shield
day anyway so be sure to subscribe to
get everything so let's start with the
characters though in the movie they're
gonna have the original guardians roster
you know sans Tony Stark that's right in
the past year he's basically been
traveling around with the card into the
galaxy it's been a lot of fun but
there's Peter quill aka star-lord Gamora
Drax the destroyer Groot and Rocket
Raccoon they changed the makeup in the
outfits just a little from the comics
just for practical reasons Rocket
Raccoon is pretty close to his comic
book bottle but Groot is the biggest
change he's just made to look a little
more humanoid in the movie the important
thing to know is that they won't be a
team at the beginning of the movie part
of the story will be them coming
together as a group the other heroes
that aren't part of the Guardians team
include yondu Nova Roman Day and Nova
prime she's like the leader of the Nova
corpse-like the Nick Fury played by
Glenn Close
the Nova corpse in this movie is
basically like shield in The Avengers
movies now let's go over the big
villains or at least the ones they've
announced that it's the collector
Ronan the accuser nebula and Korath
they're a bunch of other actors listed
in unnamed or secret roles the most
important being Sean Gunn he's the
brother of director James Gunn a Comic
Con he said that he'd have a really
important part in the movie but he
didn't say what it was so he could have
just been joking and he'll turn out to
be a janitor or something or it could
turn out to be some huge character like
the supreme intelligence but one of the
biggest unnamed roles though is fan OHS
he won't be in the movie but because
he's such a big part of the Guardians
storyline he will be part of the story
of the movie he just won't be a
character in it it is possible that
he'll be involved in the post-credits
scene if it's not ant-man related the
writers have said that he's a galactic
presence in the movie so he exists and
people know about him but he's not a
huge part of the plot the collector and
Ronan the accuser are the main
antagonists so if you're not familiar
with the characters or you haven't read
the comics in a while here's a quick
breakdown of the major characters Peter
quill aka star-lord is the son of a
human woman
and the Emperor of the Sparta Empire
also humanoid that's why he looks like a
normal person
the
first debuted in the comics in 1976 some
of the character traits we'll see in the
movie are his Deadpool level
wisecracking abilities and a reservoir
of 80s pop cultural references he's like
the king of bad jokes he's a good analog
for a smarter version of Han Solo if Han
Solo were prince of an entire galaxy I
think they did that in Spaceballs he's
the main protagonist of the film and
he'll be the one to kind of round up the
other Guardians and make them a team
then there is Gamora you absolutely have
to read the current comic book run
because she is hilarious in it not
because she tells jokes she's always the
serious person that everyone reacts to
whenever she does something really
hardcore she and Tony Stark have the
funniest sexual encounter I've ever seen
that character have in the movie Zoe
Saldana is sporting red hair which is a
little different from the original
character but she and Drax both have
green skin so the color change just
makes them look a little better notice
that the color red is a big theme too
from Peter Quill's jacket to Drax's
tattoos to Kimora's hair I love the way
this movie looks visually it's like
classic Star Wars very lived-in very
dirty originally in the comics just like
the other Guardian she's the last
surviving member of her race and Thanos
kind of takes her in and turns her into
a weapon of mass destruction so part of
her story in the movie will be Peter
quill convincing her to cut ties with
Thanos and join the good side
she isn't any less hardcore for it she
just starts killing bad guys instead of
good guys I cannot wait to see Zoe
Saldana going berserk with giant weapons
Karine never looked so good next up is
Drax the destroyer he looks like Gamora
but he's actually a human person whose
consciousness was transplanted into
another body by a person named Chronos
he was created by Chronos as a weapon to
use against Thanos it's unknown if
Cronus's in the movie but when we first
meet Drax he's on a prison ship and
Peter quill has to bust him out the
character in the comic books got wrecked
conned a lot over the years so they'll
probably be sticking with the most
recent version of his comic book history
I'm really interested to see how they
handle the more supernatural magical
qualities of the character in the movie
or if they just wash over all that and
make him smashy like the Hulk next up is
Groot and Rocket Raccoon and they kind
of come as a pair Groot just like Gamora
is also the only surviving member of his
race he can absorb wood to regenerate
himself and if he's ever destroyed or
blown up he can regrow himself from a
single splinter so in the comic books
they play with this a lot he gets blown
up in rock
racoon always sticks one of his twigs in
a pot of water he's known for only
speaking the words I am Groot but that's
just what human ears pick up he does
have a real language but only Rocket
Raccoon can understand him just like Han
Solo is the only non droid on the
Millennium Falcon that can understand
what Chuy's saying Rocket Raccoon in
keeping with the motif is the only one
of his kind in the universe he was
actually created in a lab so he was
originally a regular animal that was
given human level intelligence and
bipedal movement so that's why he walks
on two legs and uses guns time to talk
about the villains the collector was
actually born right after the Big Bang
so he's one of the oldest living beings
in the universe he's ancient
in the movie Benicio del Toro described
him as being like space Liberace which
just makes me laugh I think that they'll
tone down his powers just to make them a
little more realistic but he collects
artifacts like you see in Odin's vault
in the Thor movies at the end of Thor
the dark world the Warriors 3 actually
gave him one of the infinity gems and he
says one down five to go
so it's really the collector and not
Thanos that will eventually semble all
five gems to form the Infinity Gauntlet
I cannot wait to see all the Easter eggs
on his ship if you remember in the
original Thor movie Odin actually has
the gauntlet but not all the gems I
don't think that Marvel is intending for
that Infinity Gauntlet to be reformed by
Thanos until Avengers 3 which is like
2019 so that's still a long ways away
next up is the other you know big big
villain that's running the accuser he's
a leader in the Kree army he has a
special legion called accusers you know
thus the name Ronan the accuser they're
like a slightly more sinister version of
the Nova corpse the Kree Empire will be
one of the big antagonists in general
for the Nova corpse in the movie but
because Ronan and the Kree Empire are a
big part of the story I'm really curious
to see if we'll see the Supreme
intelligence they haven't officially
announced it yet so it's just a theory
but it would be really cool to see now
we need to talk about Karen Gillan or
nebula
yay for Doctor Who fans she's another
person on fan OSes team in the comics in
the movie she'll be working with Ronan
the accuser and she'll have this really
interesting backstory relationship with
Gamora technically they do both work for
Thanos at least at the start of the
movie
unlike amour though nebula will be evil
through and through for the duration of
the movie where as you know Gamora joins
the guardians at a certain point the
last major villain is Korra he's kind of
like an evil scientist for the Kree in
the comics he works with fan OHS Ronan
and the Kree Empire to develop
cybernetic soldiers in the mood
I'm just expecting him to be developing
really sinister technology that Ronan
will use against the Nova corpse and the
Guardians but based on the clips we've
seen and what we know about the movie so
far let me know what are you most
excited to see and what are your biggest
questions like I said since there are so
many things to talk about I'm probably
gonna start doing a Marvel movie video
every Tuesday along with my shield
videos so be sure to subscribe to get
all that stuff it's gonna be a lot of
fun I'm really excited I will be posting
that full trailer later tonight you can
click here to get that video I'll add
the annotation as soon as I post it and
you can click here to get my breakdown
of the Captain America Winter Soldier
trailer thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight high fives